With over $95 million inhabitants,
Egypt is the biggest country in the Arab
wells and yes I know what you're
thinking on Indonesia and Pakistan,
bigger than Egypt,
they Muslim to well,
yes,
they all live yet,
but make no mistake,
there is a difference between Arab and
Muslim.
Islam is simply a religion.
While Arabic is a culture or race and
especially a language inside this Arab
world,
Egypt isn't only the most populous
country.
It's one of the most influential.
This is why the Arab League has its
headquarters on the Taquerias Square in
the very center of Cairo.
And why news like this?
It's like worrying.
Egypt rises to 300,
five people in their deadliest terrorist
attack.
Nonetheless,
despite the latest news,
Egypt is changing faster than we might
think,
maybe urine under the Arab spring in
2011 thousands of people protested for
days to overthrow a Haas Niamh Uber Act.
The dictator who ruled the country back
then a year later,
the Muslim Brotherhood gains power ready
to defend the country into the pyramids
of an Islamic republic,
but now in 2017,
the Egyptian politics off taking a 180
degree shift.
Gypsy government closes 27,000 mosques
to fight terrorism.
So now the question becomes,
well,
how did we get here and Egypt of coming
a secular country.
While today we're going to answer those
questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at the history
Muslim Brotherhood
that all three names here defined
Egypt's history in the last 60 years.
NASA,
Sadat and Mubarak,
these three politicians have a common
ingredients.
They will all dictators that fully the
principles of Arab socialism.
This was the trend,
the ideology back then,
our cocktail that combined a centralized
economy,
authoritarian leadership and secularism
must make a mistake because socialist as
they claim to be,
none of these needles had any problem
with changing their rubles into dollars.
As soon as the Soviet Union disappeared.
In fact,
Sadat recognize the state of Israel ends
during the 19 eighties.
Egypt was already an ally of America,
and as you know,
befriending America in this part of the
world puts you on the radical Islam,
the bullseye.
This is why Uber Mubarak prosecuted
every Islamic movement.
Part of this repression was to avoid the
terrorist attacks that became pretty
frequent in the 19 nineties,
but uber and also had other motivations.
He wanted to stop any potential
challenge to his authoritarian rule and
guests.
You the only organized group here at
replacing was well and yes,
that would be the Muslim Brotherhood.
Despite being a client destined movement
since 1954,
the Muslim Brotherhood is the most
organized grassroots organization sense
Egypt's independence
today,
thousands of members and millions of the
goal is to turn Egypt into an Islamic
republic compliant with Sharia Law and
the principles of the Koran.
Nonetheless,
the Muslim Brotherhood isn't the only
radical group in this country.
Here we can also find the Salafist
superseded the same goals,
but by different means.
The guys you see on the screen now then
was an brothers,
as you can see,
they dress in a very western fashion,
cities,
et cetera.
Now these other guys,
all the Salafist members,
do you see the difference?
Salafi have traditional Muslim clothes,
beard sounds the every bar on their
foreheads is created after hitting the
ground so many times while praying to
Mecca.
Okay?
As you can probably figure it out from
the name,
the Salafi is wanting to live long.
The first Muslims,
the Socorro,
Salafi did.
However,
the Muslim brothers are way more
pragmatic in better organized than
members,
infiltrate government institutions,
and they have no problem disclosing
their intentions when they speak to the
western media.
We are not terrorists.
The Muslim Brotherhood's philosophies
inspired by an understanding of Islam
that emphasizes the values of social
justice,
equality,
and the rule of law God dot spokesperson
for the Muslim Brotherhood.
In other words,
both the salaries and the Muslim
Brotherhood have the same goals,
but different strategies.
Today,
the salar fists have a political party
you called our nor,
and this has nothing to do with the
Muslim brothers.
As you can imagine.
The radicals don't like each other very
much.
Remember this,
because we will come back to it later
anyway.
During the 19 eighties,
the military dictatorship of Hosni
Mubarak attacked both of these groups.
In fact,
since the year 1981,
Egypt has been in a neverending state of
emergency where every political
dissident is sent to jail.
This means thousands of fists and Muslim
brothers spending decades behind bars,
and as you can imagine,
neither the European Union nor the
United States did anything to stop this.
At the end of the day,
nobody wanted to see the Islamic
radicals in the government.
If this was not enough,
after the young Kapoor,
warm Egypt had become a good ally of
Israel and their economy,
it was on fire.
Think about it.
This country has all the ingredients for
a world class tourism industry,
the Pyramids denial,
the desert,
the Red Sea.
You can say that by the year 2000,
you couldn't label yourself a traveler
if you didn't have an Egyptian stamp on
your passport.
So for 30 years and had a free pass to
rule Egypt that,
wait just a second,
because in 2011 things really changed
our signals,
Egypt succession by taking someone to
Washington news only exist when made
both the citizens and some factions of
the army.
Equally enraged.
Having a dictator is one thing.
Having a hereditary density of power is
quite another.
This is how the Arab spring canes,
Egypt's and why Mubarak out to resign,
a year later,
parliamentary ends.
Presidential elections were held.
We're talking about a country that has
decades under a dictatorship where the
only strong political movements other
than the government itself by the
Salafis and the Muslim Brotherhood.
So I guess he won those elections.
Yes,
it was the Muslim Brotherhood led by the
guy you see on the screen.
Now,
Mohammed,
wait a minute because things are way
more complex unless you are Saudi Arabia
and you are sitting on a pile of soil.
Radical Islam isn't good for managing an
economy.
So in less than one year Egypt's
economy,
it absolutely sank.
Thousands of people lost their jobs and
inflation skyrockets.
Meanwhile,
mostly his main goal was to Islam as the
government stop the division of power
and shield his own power.
Then you've got to add into this
equation,
the army,
as we said before,
Egyptian defense forces on new big fan
of Islamist groups,
and this is how when you play,
I came into the picture,
Marshall,
Abigail,
fertile cc was the head of the Egyptian
armed forces.
He met the leaders of the opposing
parties including the Salafist and
basically said something like,
okay,
so Doug Morris,
he and his friends,
they're really screwing up.
The government's help me set to the
candidates are and we can put things
back in order and as we say here,
a visual politic.
As it was said Sir,
it was done land of the pharaohs.
By the year 2013,
the Egyptian army kicked mostly out of
the governments.
That's as policy was to make the Muslim
Brotherhood and illegal organization
again.
Of course,
protesters went to the streets and it's
hundreds of them died and thousands of
them were sent to jail.
But in June of 2014 new elections were
held,
and I say elections there because there
was virtually a single candidate I'll cc
and he managed to get 97 percent of the
vote.
The other except candidate was a guy
with a zero percent chance of winning,
called Habonim some bar heap.
He got the other three percent of the
vote.
So maybe you've seen the movie,
the Dark Knight.
There's this amazing quote,
it says you either die a hero or you
live long enough to see yourself become
the villain.
Well,
this could have been coined by LCC
himself.
In fact,
in the last few years,
Egypt has become the world's number one
leader in people given the death
penalty.
But not only that,
in just three years,
the government has closed over 27,000
mosques further.
There is no freedom of speech
whatsoever.
And yes,
I know what you're thinking here.
The Islamic fanatics are pretty angry
about this.
Well,
actually the opposite is true.
Do you remember how I said that?
The Salafist and the Muslim Brothers
aren't good friends?
Well,
I was definitely not kidding about that.
You should ultra conservative Islam a
back isis,
seek to eclipse brotherhood bots.
Wait just a minute because things are
not good for the Salafist.
See them.
Of course lcc gave them enough so they
could fill the roles left by the Muslim
brothers,
but those Egyptian believers,
he wanted to go to a mosque,
have to go to those controlled by the
oil as hot emanates,
which is under government to control,
but you know what the biggest problem is
here that are less and less believers in
Egypt.
The percentage of youngsters who pray
daily has halved in less than $5.
Yes,
a barometer in the year,
2011,
84 percent of the population supported
Sharia law influencing politics in 2016,
that percentage fell to 34 percent,
but not only that,
I'll cc himself,
celebrates the Christian Christmas in
the Coptic Cathedral of Kairos year
after year.
In other words,
Egyptian society,
that's becoming more and more secular,
but before you get too excited,
wait just a moment because this could
change at any moments.
First of all,
lccs popularity fell in 2017.
A good share of Egyptians do not like
the fact that he gave Saudi Arabia
sovereignty over two islands in the red
seat.
They also don't like the repression
either.
In fact,
newsline,
this kind of resembles x time clair
state of emergency after deadly church
attacks on the other hands that your
comedy is most Egyptians named worry.
Despite the unemployment rate's still
going down,
it's still over 12 percent and these are
the official figures.
Some experts say that it might be over
20 and displayed all of this.
The government is working on pharaoh
like projects Egypt to build new capital
paid for by China after this,
the terrorist attacks,
and we can only conclude the
[inaudible].
Governments is failing more than it is
succeeding.
So now the question is,
do you believe Egypt's can turn into a
secular country the way neighboring tune
is,
he admits,
or do you think lccs governments is Deja
Vu of uber x and that eventually we will
see a brand new Arab spring in this
country?
Well,
these leave you answer in the comments
below.
We'd love to hear from you and if you
want to know what happened in Tunisia,
well dude,
check out this other video and of course
visit our friends that reconsider media.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that are not mine,
and don't forget to subscribe.
We publish brand new videos every single
week,
so hit that subscribe button and capture
every post and also,
if you like this video,
please give it a thumbs up.
As always,
I'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast.